most people want to be kajillionaires
that's the dream
after this person and clear
now
there's a camera there there
and there
cash no mini order this is not a cheap
tie
most people want to be kajillionaires
that's the dream that's how they get you
hooked hooked on sugar hooked on
caffeine
cry cry cry me i prefer to just skim
so do i february march
april uh we may have to pay an
installment
rent is an installment it's a monthly
installment they are real characters
super unique
but you vouch for them right
she learned to forge before she learned
to write well actually that's how she
did learn to write
my favorite movies are the ocean 11
movies this is exactly the kind of thing
that i've been wanting
so what do your parents do hon hon
you've never called me that
but you could if it was a job though
right
[Music]
you're addicted to them they're my
parents
in what sense we split everything three
ways we have since i was little
i don't want to do it that way this time
don't
[Music]
you want us to be false
faking people we don't make pancakes
or wrap up little birthday presents
or call you sweetheart or baby
or do a little dance
i always thought it was insulting to
treat you like a child
and i thought we agreed on that we can
only ever
be how we are
this is the way the big one starts if
you're lucky you'll get crushed
and then you just die right then in
there
[Music]